artists are vented Ozzy has his studio
in this courtyard it's small and dark
but he says it's all he can afford rents
are high in the Albanian capital Tirana
yet his father was once a high-ranking
member of the Communist Party and a
member of the Politburo but in 1975
Albanian dictator in verochka
had him arrested and executed him two
years later no one knows what happened
to his body
Te'o Dozie who also goes by the name Ben
was 22 years old at the time and was
studying painting he was incarcerated
for 15 years spending most of that time
doing forced labour in a mine it gave me
a lot of opportunity to think about the
Albanian saying mankind's greatest enemy
is not hunger or disease but mankind
itself still the artist isn't bitter
painting has helped him overcome the
dark years of albania's repressive
communist past German Deutsche
dictatorial I keep asking myself was
this dictatorship madness we'll have to
uncover that piece by piece so uncommon
on your meeting marina but I don't
harbor any resentment my mother and
father were both part of that system my
own family and they were devoured by a
slight Thor whom society denounced for
that hear it why should I hold others
responsible
why shouldn't I look to myself for
answers I I think it's quite difficult
the file on his family is missing and is
likely in the archives of the Seeger Amy
Albania's former secret police all Te'o
dozy has left of his father are a few
old photos but now that the Albanian
Parliament has
voted to open up the Segura me files
he's hoping to find some answers after
waiting 25 years still critics say that
Albania needs to do more to really deal
with its past former members of the
secret police and communist officials
still hold high-ranking posts even
twenty years on we still have people
from the old regime the politicians
charged with opening up the files of the
same mentality the morality is the same
today as it was back then
there's no difference it's estimated
that one in five Albanians collaborated
with the secret police during the
Communist era many went on to hold plum
posts in the new Albania the mistrust
created divides even families we just
look to the future in the past you only
find problems and old wounds don't open
them up won't do anything for Albania oh
yes it will it'll advance things the
files are going anyway we're talking
about poor old folks who already have
one foot in the grave but historian
novella Nika says that even if many of
the files have been destroyed people
have a right to discover the truth she
ran the Albanian state archive for years
in a country that suffered so much it
was really quite difficult I too would
have preferred that the law had come
into effect much earlier but better late
than never the Segura me casts a long
shadow to this day
Albania secret police worked in the
building called the House of Leaves
since it was covered in vines now it's
falling apart some want to make it into
a memorial Te'o Dozie thinks that's
crazy for us that building was a vile
place I don't want to go anywhere near
referendum but he does want to find out
what really happened to his father to
shed some light on the darkest chapter
of his life